- [Kelly Clarkson] There are
countless stories online,
but this is the time I
present the best of the best.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
All right. So let's face it.
It's tough for restaurant
workers these days,
between the pandemic
and grouchy customers,
no one has it easy, which is why
this next story is so
cool and so heartwarming.
When a restaurant in London
found out a blind woman was
celebrating her birthday,
check out what they did.
(dishes clinking)
- Here you go, we want to wish you
a happy birthday.
Thank you!
- [Woman] So Nat, um I want you
to give me your hand.
(gasps) Hang on.
No freaking way!
They did not!
- You guys are amazing.
Oh my gosh! Are you kidding me?
(laughs)
(applause)
- I'm like every time it gets me,
it's the coolest thing ever.
How sweet is that?
So we have that customer
on the line right now.
What's up Natalie?
- [Natalie] Hi Kelly. Oh my gosh.
It's so exciting to meet you.
How are you?
- Oh my gosh. I'm so great.
And honestly, I watch
the video every time and
it's just, first of all,
it's so cool that they
went out of their way,
like who knew that they would know Braille
and how to do that.
Like, and it was just so cool.
Your reaction was so like
joyful and so exciting
and also was it a good birthday?
- It was incredible.
Absolutely incredible.
I saw a show on the west
end with my producer,
we went out for dinner, and oh,
just so many more things.
It was incredible.
- Oh my gosh.
Well what's really incredible
is that the restaurant
didn't even know you were coming.
So this wasn't even planned, right?
- No, we had no reservation.
We just walked in. They
found out I was blind,
that it was my birthday, and at one point
my producer got up to go to the bathroom
and they asked her if they could do this,
they said yes, and it went from there.
It was, it was absolutely incredible.
- It was so, like you figuring out
what happened is happening
is the coolest moment.
Oh my God.
It makes me feel so good.
It must have been the world to you, right?
Just somebody like, you know,
took the time to do that.
And it wasn't even planned.
- Exactly. It was unbelievable.
I, I mean, first of all,
it was such a surprise
because when Claire said,
"Give me your hand" I mean, obviously,
you know, being blind, you can't just
glance down and see that someone's
put a dessert out in front of you.
So, you know, putting
out my hand, not knowing
what to expect and then
feeling "happy birthday"
packed in melted chocolate when
I didn't even know anything
was happening, it was just,
I, yeah, it blew my mind.
And I, I spent the entire
night just a mess afterwards,
the camera goes off and I'm crying.
The staff's crying,
people around me crying.
But what was really funny was that
I didn't even know it was going to happen.
So they asked at one point,
they came over to us and they said,
"Oh, we'd love to bring you
a complimentary dessert"
And I go, "Oh, thank you so much,
but we actually already
have plans for dessert."
So I was like, no, no, no
(laughs)
So I was definitely
giving them pointed looks
being like, no, no, no.
"We'd love to stay for
a complimentary dessert
wouldn't we Natalie?"
And I was like "yeah
that would be amazing."
- And first of all, Natalie,
we never turned down free dessert.
Who turns down free dessert.
- I know! What was I thinking?
- That's crazy, Natalie.
Oh my God. Well, I'm so glad
you had such a great birthday.
I'm so glad people made
you feel as special
as you obviously are.
Thank you so much, we're
liking your posts right now.
Right?
- Aww, Thank you so much.
- Absolutely. Oh, and that's not all
our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to
erasable pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
they want to celebrate
those creating fearlessly,
just like you.
So in celebration, they are giving you
a thousand dollars, how does that sound?
- Wow. Oh my gosh!
- That's a lot of dessert, Natalie.
Go get all the dessert you want.
That's what I say.
(laughs)
- Thank you.